I just wanted there to be a true
authentic real record
of my life Pamela Anderson is opening up
about the only time she was ever truly
in love while appearing on the newest
cover of People magazine hitting new
stands Nationwide Friday in an excerpt
from her upcoming Memoir love Pamela
exclusively obtained by people the
actress says the divorce from Tommy was
the hardest lowest most difficult point
of my life
Pamela also appeared on CBS Sunday
Morning where she detailed Where it All
Began
Tommy and I fell in love it felt like
this really safe place he would arrive
at the house on a horse with covered you
know in a full night gear on knight in
shining armor and read a scroll to me it
was just so hyper heightened but it felt
good it felt like oh my gosh this is
what it's all about this is true love it
was so romantic it was so over the top
but that's not a foundation for a
sustainable love no it's not a
foundation for sustainable love I
haven't done that yet and in her
upcoming Netflix docu series Pamela a
love story it's a 55 year old addresses
their Whirlwind romance and of course
that Infamous sex tape I blocked that
stolen tape out of my life in order to
survive and now that it's all coming up
again I feel sick
I want to take control of the narrative
for the first time Pamela adds to People
magazine I live a more romantic life now
that I'm alone than I did in
relationships
when I got a chance to speak with Pamela
recently she revealed that she's
currently living single life happily at
her grandparents old farmhouse on
Vancouver Island a green really vividly
here I get great ideas here I wrote my
whole book from here I just feel like
this is something
this is It's just packed full of full of
energy and history with the man and it
just feels like my face is my safe Zone